Sí muy buenos días para ti Eduardo
mendúa era un dirigente que es
responsabilizada por las relaciones
internacionales de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de Ecuador
Eduardo mendú había participado el
reciente consejo de asamblea nacional
que había realizado la Econo y el pasado
viernes se veía a la izquierda cuando
participaba en esa mesa de diálogo que
habría convocado la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas Eduardo mendúa
también que era un dirigente de
protestaba De igual forma en contra de
la extracción minera Eduardo mendúa era
un dirigente previamente hace siete
meses ya se habría asesinado a su
hermano y esto ha generado una gran
cantidad de reacciones no solo por parte
del ejecutivo nacional que ha dicho que
va a investigar también se ha producido
una reacción por parte de la fiscalía
que en el día de hoy la mañana de hoy ya
había dicho que en vez de un operativo
ya se habría detenido a una
De igual forma también me ha generado
una reacción por parte del presidente de
la república rechazando este
cometimiento de este asesinato también a
Se ha producido una reacción por parte
de el responsable de representación de
los pueblos indígenas de la uno donde
pide esclarecer este tipo de asesinato
Cuál es el contexto que es donde se
realiza este asesinato de Eduardo mendúa
se produce en medio de una fuerte
tensión y un clima político recordemos
que el viernes pasado la conae ha
solicitado exigido la renuncia del
presidente de la república todo esto
porque también la asamblea nacional
emitió un informe también esto también
previo a un informe que había emitido un
sitio web digital conocido como la posta
donde se emite un informe de presunta
relación de Rubén cherres un vínculo con
el daniro carrera que es el cuñado del
presidente de la República en trama de
corrupción donde se habla que estaría un
nexo con el narcotráfico todo este
contexto político la confederación de
las ciudades indígenas pide también la
renuncia o al apartarse al costado del
presidente de la república de ambiente
en forma le exige la asamblea nacional
que encauce un juicio político en contra
el presidente de la república esto ha
producido ya conmoción social el
presidente de la ironías isas declaró
esta mañana donde exige una
investigación Al respecto porque han
dicho que no confían en las
investigaciones El Ejecutivo nacional
bueno es que este hecho se produce en un
ambiente político tenso que usted nos
está describiendo en el Ecuador la conai
ya venía pidiendo la salida de Guillermo
lasso ahora responsabiliza el estado por
la muerte de mendúa que puede esperarse
después de este asesinato
Pero bueno hay que ser muy cauto y
específico cuando leónidas Isa y la
conair responsabiliza a El Ejecutivo
nacional ellos básicamente lo que han
dicho es que responsabilizan por omisión
al que El Ejecutivo nacional no sea
preocupado por la seguridad en sus
territorios básicamente porque El
Ejecutivo nacional ha permitido nuevas
concesiones de 30 pozos petroleros y De
igual forma de 11 concesiones mineras y
ellos aseguran de que El Ejecutivo
nacional es tiene una cuota de
responsabilidad y De igual forma también
las empresas petroleras porque actúan
rechazando la militarización de estas
empresas en sus entornos territoriales